só hoje vou ensinar como fazer
não este não estiver dentro do avião que
voou muito alto quer dizer todos prof
eu vou mais a 1 tem maior tão podre
pouco de ser melhor eo papel que eu já
criei sempre e como eu achei muito
simples eu base neste avião conhecido
internacionalmente em frei porque daqui
na cauda que é muito flexível e isso é
muito bom então eu vou ficar itaú
aerodinâmica não era muito boa
o site é o princípio é o mesmo usado nas
asas dos aviões em que aqui tem maior
leveza e que por baixo é luiz é que o
princípio da folha de papel 29 sobrado
aqui fazer isto é um princípio física
foi o professor nas aulas de deus pois é
essa e publicar o meu deus será muito
funciona é o bico que estraga muito
facilmente palavras porque um teste do
estudo
o show pessoal pra você deve saber a
quantidade não foi aberta quatro opções
e mais incrível trata se quiser fazer
ficou na folha branca e material que vai
de outubro a abril ou maio
ou em caso de funk
embora brinca
anderson triângulo retângulo
a extensa funciona essa design papel
pessoas escrevem que as coisas
você passa fica mais vai produzir e hoje
estou forte e vai receber neste lote
ou seja depende do sucesso em produzir
um ponto
assim porque
é obra vai cantar aqui está fazendo por
aqui
agora para dar mais jeito de fazer um
passinho quebrar tesouro eu acho que eu
acredito
veja que fica na infância vai desde a
praça já é reincidente
está agora
chegar aqui
agora vou ter que vir a esta parte tem
seu povo à noite
é isso
obrigado vocês podem perguntar o senhor
à noite você quer ficar
da maneira que foi grande apesar de
também não usar sobre uma questão de
orientação na hora do ataque
o texto
isso aqui é um termo muito pesado que
você tá na quarta feira explicou a moça
artística de onde pegou muito alto
acho que vocês vão ter muito peso
concentrará feito para conseguir ser
lançados possível chegar em peso e
distribuir a força habitual
agora sim
agora podendo assim aqui vai
agora você me deixar aqui dois tempos o
chute aqui vai crescendo juntos e braga
foi a maneira que fique igual nesta
quarta quinta e sexta aqui você pode ter
uma vez que deve ser mais rigoroso nos
aguentar como esta parte para cima desta
vez quito quando integrava o elenco
oficial
o assunto aqui
se fosse para fazer bem popular
a festa da partilha seja clubes era
dinâmica do rio lançou mais ao ataque e
que são vício que acontece aqui que
fazer esta quarta e quinta questão que
fica mais chique né
aqui a pressão é melhor estágio com o
consumo aumenta a opção de bolacha
província assim vai fazer pra casa um
carro eléctrico não pode usar clínica
estar de volta aqui manhã eu já fui em
hasake o entrevistado
ai causa vai entrar numa todos
khartoum
eu rezo pra mãe
por aqui é mais ou menos de quatro
centímetros
deixo aqui tinha 43 20 que já tem
barriga da mãe dólar lá fora
a tese porque
também por lá
sim brito
este espaço foi idêntica publicar causa
ela não foi lançado um ator ao balançar
alterou a trajetória do avião
e agora como é assim eu colocar no tempo
nós para ser fofo
ele está colado e pede um tempo tanto
que fiquei nas juntas e ela sabia que
ele ia soltar pipa cola fita crepe ou
então com o mesmo tempo
estou esperto está tal